що думають про берлін про дональда трампа
45 президента США просто тому людей
поблизу гурський хмурить самий сюди ще
дня приїжджають туристи з усього світу
початкових зусиль не на чини замість
сайт для мене били люди на сокрушимо аали
без розуміння бага тих промов цін
забезпечено загорілися до пелег вітру
ми його вибрали б wing прогнозу роботи
америку знову великою можна трохи йому в
дасти це кіно тасс зрештою щура
наш атакував та як raynox США вона могла
знає і in shell президента всі овочі
можна його студенти меншою думкою ніш
туристи зап це йому у на та найстарішому
університет Берліна
а сама я б сказав у відкритий до трампу
і нано-лижі дутих любить початку здається
дональд трамп нічого написано на свої
посаді
ольга також і критичний чудо хутра оси
було чудо його ви наче ксенофобію
про плани свист істину на кордоні зміг
зберігся на fine харчуються мало
балонів на психо лише й полеміки а не
чекай на нього та політика
вулиця і ден оптимістично що і можна про
його сказати можна його в орду спалив від і
присіли keys трамп наук вулицях столиці
та у районі more than when майна я дуже
добрий славу
скажімо 5 тут на астані комунальних
виборах голосував за праву тату листок
сальто в над і ви для не начини че знай
димом і тут більше про фініки в трампу
бального
чудово людина і кому ж за себе постояти
багатий чого обіцяв a loving hut з
робот хочеш на царя в цьому мабуть
економічний плюси в тонусі вин хоче під
бате пробив робочому місці США
байди кульки hause ви дуб і гарбуз
величина вт і
чудовий буду за хибними третина окраїн
приживеться на дайвінгу ту ж добро
знаєш що робою області але сам собі
збирає 6 видів майже
прийнятого вінс таяться душа витрачав його
що навіть але мені та фауни ви повинні я
[ __ ] санацію займ те що сказала і нам
берлінці вид побачи а у після цього ням 55
адже сотки у німців пари канон шукаю трамп
матово негативний флем наймає чину
теж і йому буду не просто змін цієї
зв'язку
ведмедик фарин з такого на такі ціни